I'm out of charge but I'm full of spite
hi welcome back to help wanted to now
nobody panic because absolutely nothing
is
different oh God no also I hope I don't
hit anything cuz I have a little less
step space than I used to all right
let's try first
aid that's not scrap baby oh use a
scanner gun to see what's wrong with
helpie uh-huh oh oh man I have missed
this I missed you helpie welcome back
the patient is prepped and ready where
medical attention begins in 3 2 1 uh-huh
the patient is suffering from help me
slide related injury oh my God are you
okay buddy are you okay due to today's
successful Salvage
Pizza
also uh-huh can anyone decode that for
me because I didn't quite get it hi
helpie it's been a while oh you bug eyed
freak oh oh you're going to be just fine
don't worry about a thing you chubby
cheek
who hey hey no no no no whoa hey
hey oh that's not right yeah yeah I'll
pause the game on you not cuz I'm afraid
it's because you smell bad all help you
what's wrong with
you does that
hurt just say if it
do
oh why I what oh his heart is
stopped
oh
clear hi hey
hey well that wasn't what I thought it
was a little baby I guess scrap baby
is
clear
clear hey whoa whoa hey whoa hey hey
hey hey
hey am I rolling just got to
remember not to do that again we don't
want anybody screaming now do we you
Bonk you Bonk
oh you get close real quick and I don't
I don't know about that one in the
eyeball okay
peekaboo I'm just going to keep this on
hand well well well well
well uh-huh I'm just going to keep this
on me just in case that happens again
who knows what could happen well this
fix
nope you don't know that that anything's
happen Okay
well shh okay so we need to put a
bandage oh actually that's a splint well
there's my splint G it's like a slab
bracelet all right this won't hurt so
you shouldn't
scream
uh-huh who wo who
W
oh well happens to the best of us iose
due to today's successful Salvage
Pizza I know how to fix
that no no I got to be good to him I got
to be good to you I'll be good to you
helpie don't move ahuh so you want the
blue
bottle no got to be you want the blue
bottle okay don't
move
some for the breath well that worked out
nicely did your heart stopped oh no oh
no oh
no no no thank you all right you're
done no one thing no malpractice here
what was it there was there was
something
else well that doesn't need a
[Music]
hammer you're making me look bad you're
making me look like I'm doing this
intentionally what it's for medicine
it's for medicine is it's for your own
good that back all right let's get that
all taken care of let's disinfect it
this won't sting
uh-huh let's get my Brillo
pad this is for something else all
right well I
did oh okay all right well no you know
I'm here normally just cuz there's noise
doesn't mean that you would get me or
something like that all right yeah it's
the operation was a success how are you
doing how you doing buddy give the Pati
into candy you want some candy is
legally binding Scream real loud if you
want candy scream really loud just candy
yeah you like that is it good for you
good good good I'm not cruel I'm not
mean what you really hogging that thing
can you squeeze this in there somewhere
just see if you can fit it in the
gaps you all right I don't know if
you're supposed to be that calm if I
just threaded in your eye or
something sh
sh all right F there you go
scenario the patient is suffering from
parental
neglect I hope not let's get this out of
the way I guess all right let's get your
let's get your this slap
ration oh my God I didn't know you could
do
that I'm not worried I'm going to keep
this on hand because we're going to need
to do some stuff some fun stuff
ow
right s squ squish calm down
uhhuh put that within reach all right
one down what's wrong with your eye you
got a fever that's what's wrong oh well
there you go say ah oh you're warm oh no
you need the yellow pill underwhelming
scented oil
the
dud what do we got rabbit animal bit
solu oh this is for a syringe that's not
you
need malaria
morsels there you go okay what's next a
TV
commercial that would have been really
cool if that happened at that
moment
uh-huh yeah ah a you son of a
back off all right I'm just going
to yank this okay well Cal okay I'm
still going to yank
it okay you done it's just an eye it was
already dead so why are you worried
about oh wow uh okay okay let's get you
a
new I just so happen to have one of
these in my kit ain't you lucky the
operation was a success it sure was now
do you want the candy give the patient
the candy you want the candy or you want
the gas which one do you want the candy
or the
gas next
scenario the patient is suffering
from oh my god
get uh-huh new I all
right oh your heart stopped
seems like you're
oh you know for all the abusa that I've
wrecked on you I don't know if the that
is the right answer oh
God ooh you got close you got a little
too close Little Too Close there all
right you okay you're about to
be no no no no Need No need no need what
is this what is that that's how you're
screaming so
much
interesting okay old lungs out new LS in
you got it don't know how you're
screaming with
these oh I just so happen to have
one all right let's get in that brain so
Chrome doome how you doing um not good I
bet any minute now that's going to go
off uhhm
uhhuh a saw you
say I have one of those surely hey how
did I miss that maybe I didn't even know
that door could
open
fascinating let's set this
down ah you son of a don't even
try it all right this uh hurt
[Music]
thing
mhm okay okay looks like they're not
around that's good I got to put my tool
away just like that let me take this oh
a new hat
great I lost it you don't need it I
don't think you need it anyway uh why
does it got to look like a real brain is
this going to what is it going to do to
you nothing the operation was a success
oh uh oh man um oh God uh give Pati
candy C is
legally H how you doing there what
happens if I just yoink oh
nothing okay just going
to just you be happy I guess you weren't
using that anyway I quit work you have
received your Fazbear first aid
certification you are now qualified to
administer medical support in all all
Fazbear entertainment franchises oh God
oh God hey you can't you couldn't do
that
right oh yay was there always a
yay I don't remember there always being
a yay ah it's you who cares not
me well that went well there you
are oh good glad you're
here aha okay good well that was a whole
lot of useless but this
isn't thank you thank you for that I
have come get your candy here candy when
she had grown she sought revenge on the
Witch and entered the forest again
willingly this time with the confidence
of age and
experience you really got to get better
at telling stories man I'm not even
hooked I'm a little hooked so I've done
the backstage stuff that's good food
prep still need to do that that's fine
asburn I 3 and a warehouse that doesn't
sound
good but I'm going to go into food prep
because there's nothing I love more than
customer service oh I'm gon to have to
get used to this combine a soda and
snack in the
blender machine to make a blendy
different combinations make a different
blend D all right so do I need to
remember those combinations because are
those
specific don't let the endos near
you of course they're here of course
they're
here yeah okay oh boy oh good welcome to
Freddy Fazbear's Fazbear theater the
next show will begin in 5 minutes uh-huh
still open still open still open open
uh-huh
there just you know this is what they do
you pre some
popcorn so you're ready oh well there it
goes okay
oh why do I don't know how to make what
oh God no oh
no oh
no oh no okay this dis appointment chips
what's
that oh God meat bites you got
it oh oh
my oh my god
oh I'm out of charge but I'm full of
spite uh-huh okay butter W my God butter
for one and then exotic blendy okay so I
need to how do I make that exotic
beverage I'm guessing that and a butter
for one is going to be what it needs to
be oh boy that's not right
stop okay put that in the blendy put
this in
here stop where are you
stop okay there we go there you
go is that good is that please tell me
that was
good oh boy okay all right that's fine
that's fine that's very
fine okay a meat pretzel
with meat pretzel with butter I don't
know how to do the butter
oh how do I do the butter
I'm not 100% sure how to do the
butter oh
butter okay meat pretzel with butter
lemon chica bar hi yeah yeah I yeah I'm
on it disappointment
chips sodina blendy okay stop you need
meat bites where are you stop
it okay there we
go two sodina blondies okay got it
should have gotten this going why am I
not doing this like I was
before
stop okay me
[Music]
fights Wham look at
that
hello okay sodina
blendy oh coming
up there's no endos here are there there
wouldn't be any right
oh oh god oh no
please H yeah okay thank you oh God okay
lemon CH bar lemon CH bar sodon you got
it that said sodon blendy yes it sure
did oh what is
that what in the world
hi hold
on oh my God oh my God oh my God oh my
God oh my God what do I do about that CH
chug you got a chica
chug stay away stay away stay away okay
oh my God that was right right tell me
that was right be good to
me thank you yes you're welcome you're
welcome t t hot dog the hot dog that's
not a good hot dog okay I guess they're
all bad hot dog with nacho
chees hot dog nacho cheese oh my God oh
my God
stop yeah Roxy nachos with nacho cheese
oh that doesn't look good I I don't I
don't know if I should okay that's fine
oh my
God oh my God okay that I'm just going
to go with that that is correct popcorn
with butter I kind of forgot that
there's butter okay popcorn with butter
oh my God don't do that DJ music
man that and an exotic beverage okay and
there you go there ding ding I hope
that's okay please tell me that's okay
is that okay it was a little
moldy oh you're welcome okay let me just
Chu that out of
there okay rock nachos with nothing okay
butter for one that's easy exotic
beverage I have it lined up right here
holy what are you oh my God don't
do any of that oh God okay all
right
Tru we oh my
god oh no wait no I need an
exotic Oh my
God exotic blendy needs uh butter butter
butter butter oh my God don't do
that okay they do move when
I don't look at him that's going right
there oh boy that was a waste the
popcorn could do it with my eyes closed
popcorn pizza
slice with nacho
cheese is that everything
yeah is that
good was that good please tell me that
was good oh my God please tell me that
was good was it good yeah
good okay okay thank
you okay brush complete that's good that
sounds good oh
oh H take some of that take some of that
take my good food M Meat
pretzel oh good yeah
that's that's what you want to see
that's really what you want
CH a message what
you
huh uh-huh purveyors of sus what was
that you said before about the
cloud supposed to be a message for me
chica trash
can uh-huh wait is that telling me
something about that trash
can is there a trash can in here there
must be a trash can in one of those
games that it's not telling me about
okay hold
on what happens if
I I still have
it this has to mean something right
right okay that has to mean something
there's got to be something to that but
for now let's go ahead and get fazer
blast out of the way throw balls Dart
gum to pop balloons that's fine hit them
with anything knock them away okay so
dart gun has been Ed into the
equation well I'm sure we can find
something a little more difficult to
test your troubling T fish
on just pick up that dark gun get this
shooting
w f were you playing those things uh-huh
so balls are everywhere wow that's nice
okie
dokie so here we
[Music]
go a oh oh
God okay let me keep this in this hand
it seems like the oh my God this this
could not be going whoa hey could not be
going
[Music]
worse oh boy this is going pretty
terribly oh
boy
[Music]
what
thought that was a scrap
thing okay well you could have got me a
little more time than
that okay where are you get out of
here oh what the
freak oh
interesting fascinating am I going to
die if those get
through nope
I don't even know if it's worth trying
to get those hi
[Music]
Bonnie man I'm not good at the dark gun
that's for sure the ark is really thrown
me off whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa oh
God I did it a hey Moon God damn
it
that
oh what the freak okay well that didn't
go well okay so so you do got to get the
doors on those things but I don't know
if it's important to do anything else it
seems like the laser is not
essential
huh oh uhoh
hello free
me from my Purgatory hello oh god oh
shoot I forgot to hit record on this
thing huh oh there I am on the new angle
oh wait no there I'm not oh there I am
on the new angle well this couldn't have
gone more terribly I can assure you that
this has uh truly been a a travesty and
I'm
stuck in the
Beyond again oh wait
but oh the game was just I just heard it
well this is truly terrible and I don't
hear a
thing great slight technical
difficulties I know all of this would be
alleviated if I just used a long USB
cable but I don't want to do that once
you've been Wireless there's no going
back can you even hear me I think you
can hear me on that but I don't know if
you can hear me on anything else if
that's recording I'm ready for this to
work immediately and never
fail
nope
aha now we're back in it okay let's try
that again so we can at least get to the
end of this one and then we can move on
to whatever else we're doing yo yoink no
not food BR fast Cade just going to get
this one out of the way all right so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
just do this J Jump Jump okay I'm
ready come on for for
go those
[Music]
things I don't know what kind of
three-handed person you expect me to
be whoa whoa whoa I see you
there hold on hold on hold on I'm not my
brain can't do both at
once okay well I can't do
either
[Music]
W who I forgot about you I forgot I
didn't even hear you I heard of the wo
man I was too busy listening to the woes
I wasn't able to hear
you
nice okay I'm not going to shoot him the
woes are
distracting
[Music]
no no no
no come
[Music]
on
[Applause]
okay oh God where are you where are you
what do you mean what do you mean where
where where
was it like under my feet or
[Music]
something whoa whoa whoa oh my God don't
do
that
Jesus don't do that again oh I need
this don't I
okay where
where where I heard
you oh I got it oh oh okay
hold on I was
[Music]
busy
who where where I don't see
you where
[Applause]
this I see you God damn
[Music]
it
uh-huh
[Music]
God damn
it heard that off to the right oh oh oh
they can be up there well that's
dumb wo oh oh oh I missed it again
that's the second time that that's
happened and I look around like an idiot
going like whoa whoa like oh that was
good
s
strange it's f for the whole family I
bet it is well I did it
yippee Yahoo I hope it's something good
ah It's that guy I've
got him sure does look like Lefty you
know if I didn't know any better I'd say
this is the same exact oh it is well
what do you know what do you know all
right that's all the time I got Lefty is
still creepier thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
thought down in the comments below and
as always I'll see
you in the next
video
[Music]
bye-bye